all right people today we're gonna be
looking at SCP 82 object class Euclid
special containment procedures in large
living quarters located at armed bio
containment area 14 have been
appropriated for the suppression and
appeasement of SCP a to while standard
weapons have little effect in policing
as cp82 cooperation is easily attained
through a charade subject is currently
under the impression that it has been
made the King of France and that its
containment area is actually a Grand
Palace designed for its protection all
interacting personnel are to be made
aware of this charade and are ordered to
follow the ruse housekeeping personnel
are to be Class D personnel only
guards tasked with the containment of
SCP a to are to be given level two
clearance but are instructed to refrain
from interacting directly with SCP 82
description SCP 82 is genetically human
however through some process either
chemical hormonal cancerous or
supernatural as cp82 has grown to giant
proportions approximately 2.4 meters
tall around 8 foot weighing over 310
kilograms about 700 pounds SCP 82 s
physical characteristics are grossly
disproportional it has a slightly
pointed balding head a large rounded
chin and jaw a bulbous nose and dark
sunken eyes subject is both overweight
and possesses a great amount of muscle
mass forearms are muscular and dangerous
with a circumference of about 71
centimeters that's 28 inches the breadth
of the subjects fist is nearly 30
centimeters along the knuckles almost 12
inches though the feet are large they
are small in proportion to the subjects
body men's size 14 us
subjects skin is tan dark and overall
physical appearance is compounded by
numerous scars the results of years at
attempts of suppression in containment
most x-rays have been difficult to
interpret because of the high density of
its muscle tissue but scans have
revealed countless bullets and even
several knife and sword blades lodged in
SCP 82's flesh as cp82 refers to itself
as furnad and speaks fluent French and
heavily accented English when it speaks
it does so through enormous clenched
teeth SCP 82 only parts teeth to eat
food and to sing subject will sing songs
of its own pleasing ranging from
forgotten Victorian era songs to modern
classical typically a while cooking and
eating as cp82 does not comb the hair on
the sides of its head but does cut it
and Shay's with a large butcher knife
originally provided for food preparation
it should be noted that even facial hair
is exaggerated a single strand being as
thick as a millimeter similar in
thickness and appearance to graphite of
a mechanical pencil occasionally SCPA
teeth who will clench its teeth so hard
that the gums bleed but it is not known
why this is considered normal the
demeanor of SCPA - is very amicable and
carefree as cp82 has accrued a wide
wardrobe over its time of incarceration
and it enjoys dressing up in many
different fashions including formal wear
military uniform has a clown and women's
clothing new pieces should be made
available on request subject often
attempts to joke and is usually quite
polite personnel often inviting them to
dinner
however visiting personnel should be
aware that at any moment as cp82 is
capable of attacking and voraciously
eating others subject will often
apologise for its lack of manners for
interrupting someone's conversation by
devouring their head while making a mess
of his quarters SCP 82's jaws are strong
enough to crack bone and it seems to
enjoy skulls attacks are seemingly
random with no motivation
whether or not subject has recently
eaten has no effect on this
cannibalistic hunger as cp82 is
incapable of differentiating fact from
fiction when he reads it or watches
television or films on several occasions
SCPA teeth who has expressed a great
desire to meet his favorite person
Hannibal Lecter and subject will believe
that all television programming is some
form of reality television
though subject has shown heightened
intelligence in the form of memory and
puzzle solving the concepts of parody
satire and fiction are beyond its
understanding SCP 82 apparently
understands the concept of lying has
shown to know when others are blatantly
lying and generally tells all these
falsehoods when asked about its past
according to SCP 82 he is a vampire a
homunculus Big Bird Andre the Giant
Napoleon obliques sidekick of Asterix
dr. bright the Hulk Alexander the Great
Captain Hook Sherlock Holmes dr.
Frankenstein and Frankenstein's monster
when questioned about these lies he
gives the excuse but I only lie when
it's through my teeth
you